all right welcome back everyone to my
round six recap from the Reykjavik open
so I actually played this game yesterday
and as you're gonna see it was a long
stressful game for me and I was really
exhausted afterwards and I just had no
energy to do the recap so doing it now
when I'm still kind of tired but at
least I have some energy so hopefully I
can get through this without falling
asleep or stumbling on my words and it
was a really like instructive and
interesting game and a lot of Rich ideas
which I'll try and cover so I was
playing against lohia soham or Sohan
mohia uh rated 2081 and as we're going
to see I'm pretty sure my opponent was
like very underrated at least so the way
he played this game uh so I started with
a London opening after E6 Bishop F4
um the reason why I played Knight F3 was
I didn't want to encounter Bishop F4 D6
uh which I thought he was capable of
playing because he has played King's
Indian in the past so I thought Knight
F3 is kind of a tricky move order
because if D6 and I have other options
of not putting the bishop on F4 but
rather playing Z4 and Knight C3
so I played Bishop F4 and he plays Pawn
to B6 and I looked at this a little bit
before the game I did see that he uh has
played Queen's Indian in the past and
this is the start of a queen's Indian
setup and generally I'm happy to play
against these setups when I play the
London uh because there's some cool
ideas after E3 Bishop to B7 and then
Pawn C4 it's not the traditional way of
playing the London usually white puts a
Pawn on C3 going for the more triangle
setup but C4 is a bit more of an
ambitious move and there's some
interesting ideas here for one if black
plays C5 which looks very standard then
white has a very strong move D5 and then
there's a cool line takes Knight C3 and
if takes there is Knight B5 and
um yeah when I uh actually when I was
lecturing at the St Louis chess club
this was years ago back in 2017. I gave
whole lecture on how to play the London
opening and how to beat good players
with the London opening and the first
game I showed in that lecture was a game
from this line where I had beaten
Fabiano caruana in an online game at
least supposedly Fabiano it was like an
honest account but pretty sure it was
Fabiano and I had one in like I think
within five more moves from this
position
um I'm not sure if this is exact
position I had against Fabiano but the
idea is after Knight A6 defending C7
white can take and if D5 there's very
strong move Queen A5
uh so there's a lot of Venom in this
line if Black's not careful and White's
completely winning in this position so
this is just a bit of opening
inspiration but my opponent played
um of I guess a more solid move Bishop
to B4
and here I played Knight F to D2 which
looks a little bit strange at first uh
you might wonder why I'm not developing
like undeveloped knights from B1 but
there's some uh some nuances where
there's cases where the Knight likes to
go to C3 and I've had play Knight C3
immediately black can induce double
pawns which I don't quite want and
Knight fd2 also has a benefit of
unleashing McQueen and there are certain
lines where the queen can come to the
king side pretty quickly uh so after
Castle A3 Bishop E7 Knight C3 I've had
this position once in a tournament game
before and there's another kind of cool
trap in this line which I should show
because it's just more inspiration to
play such a line for whites if black
plays C5 here which I had oh I forgot
what year it was I think it was like
2017 or 2018 no it was 2016 or 2017.
it's at the Pan Am Collegiate tournament
against GM indich he played this move
and there's really nice response to play
D5 and it's another thematic Pawn
sacrifice except White's not really
sacking a pawn because we can win it
back after takes takes
um if Knight takes or it's Queen F3
immediately with the pin injitch took
with the bishop and after takes takes
Queen F3 this has been played before
it's actually uh an opening line that's
known to be good for whites after Knight
C7
I don't want to take and take the Rook
because my queen gets trapped in the end
after Knight C6 but very strong move
Queen B7 and
um yeah this is this would have all been
opening preparation uh but my opponents
avoided all of this
and rather than playing Pawn C5
uh he played Pawn D5 which is opting for
a more kind of Queen's Gambit decline
setup this is a very typical setup for
Black against the Queen's gambits and I
think D5 is probably the best move and
it's a move that I should have been more
prepared for but I'll admit that I was
out of like specific preparation that's
at this point but I knew General ideas
like I knew opening principles that I
should develop my bishop and Castle so I
started with taking we traded on D5 I
play Bishop D3 Pawn C5 I bring my knight
to F3 and after Knight D7 I castle and I
thought okay it seems to be like a very
fine setup still resembles a London uh
we have this tension between the pawns
now it turns out that castling may have
been a slight inaccuracy because I just
underestimated Black's next move which
he played is Pawn to C4
and generally I don't mind seeing this
uh in a Queen's Gambit decline structure
because after Bishop to C2
um there's no more pressure on D4 and I
thought that uh at least early on in the
game I thought that I'll have ideas of
95 and attacking on the king side but uh
it turns out that black has equally if
not greater pressure on the queen side
after this move Pawn to B5 there's
already ideas of storming down with A5
and B4 and I think at this point like
after he played B5 I was realizing that
the position actually isn't so easy to
play for whites I started with a move
rookie one after I played this move I
just for granted it especially after he
played A5 because I realized my Rook
doesn't have a great purpose on anyone
and this may have been caused by just
the fatigue this was my second round of
the day earlier in the day I played Anna
crowling and then after my game with
Anna we analyzed on her stream for uh
like 60 to 90 minutes so it's just kind
of a Non-Stop day for me and uh kind of
showed with my moves like playing
playing a move that didn't really have a
clear purpose especially because white
almost never wants to play E4 allowing
the bishop to breathe more fire along
the long diagonal E4 would also weaken
my uh my d-pawn which I don't want so
after A5 I opted for Knight E5 and then
we traded and I took with the pawn
trying to imbalance things I mean I'm
playing someone who is about 300 points
lower rated and I thought that if I'm
gonna try and win the game I might as
well um make the position a bit more
imbalanced and what this does even
though it doubles my pawns it opens up
the file for my queen and I had seen
that after he plays Queen D7 I can put
my queen on D4 and then try and play
against this uh kind of backwards d-pawn
on the half open file but he played well
here he started with Rook C8 preparing
Bishop C5
I drop back to G3 so I unleash the
fourth rank for my queen he plays Pawn
B4 I play Queen F4 he plays Pawn G6
which is a very uh nice prophylactic
move if you know this in this position I
was threatening Bishop 5 so G6 simply
prevents that now I still wanted to
get this bishop to do something because
currently it's just staring at this Pawn
chain so I was happy with my next move
is to play Bishop to D1 which sets up
the same skewer idea now for in Bishop
G4 but it also has ideas of bringing the
bishop to F3 where it would just be a
more active Square to challenge the long
diagonal
and then he played in another
prophylactic move Pawn H5 so preventing
my Bishop from winning material
I play Bishop H4 here offering the trade
he takes I take and then he plays Pawn
to C3 and at this point I realized
there's actually like a lot to worry
about for white because this uh
especially the C Pawn is becoming more
and more dangerous and I can't allow
black to play C2 and B3 and A4 and just
have this Pawn chain all up in my
territory so uh here I decide to take
after takes I put the Rook on C1 and I
wanted to create a situation where this
Pawn is more of a weakness than a
strength and pretty much for the rest of
the game the strategy for both sides
revolves around the C pod because black
is constantly trying to not only defend
it but make it a weapon and I'm trying
to just blockade it and uh eventually
try and win it and treat it as a
weakness so it's a very interesting kind
of strategy from here he started with
Rook C4 hitting my queen I play Queen G5
now I'm aligning with the King hitting
the pawn so I'm threatening Bishop H5
but he simply plays Queen d8 offering
the queen trade and at this point I
don't really have a choice other than to
take it I didn't want to play Queen H6 I
thought that was going in a little bit
too deep so I took on Dietz he takes
back and I'm just realizing I have lost
internet connection so maybe I'll take a
brief pause and wait for the internet to
come back let me get some water too
shout out to Icelandic water it's very
fresh I don't know if it's Mountain
Water or lake water snow water
maybe melted snow okay my internet just
completely died oh it's back okay good
timing I have to stay hydrated though
okay so what was I saying oh yeah we
traded queens and now it's a rook and
Bishop ending but very unbalanced uh
like pawns are kind of scattered uh
there's multiple potential Pawn
weaknesses for both sides but as we're
gonna see over the next few moves Bishop
B3 Rook C5 Rook D1 Bishop C6 uh black is
pretty much in full control like it's
actually very difficult for me to Target
anything in the position
like the move I wanted to play did I
play it no I play Bishop C2 here I
wanted to play Rook D3 and hit the pawn
uh but there was a problem with this
move
was I scared of
yeah my brain is kind of mashed potatoes
at this point what was I scared of why
didn't I just go after the pawn
take take oh yeah okay so this is
actually an instructive moment that
black doesn't really have a great way to
defend the pawn but black has a way to
counter attack and uh really clamp down
with the move Rook B8
and yeah the reason why I didn't go for
this is because if I take the pawn takes
takes there's back rank issues uh mainly
Bishop A4 I believe and then if I take
uh Rook B1 comes with mate and if I play
Bishop A2 then Rook B2 comes and my
Bishop's essentially trapped because
it's tied down to defending the back
rank mates so yeah life was kind of sad
if I can't play Rook to D3 and Rook bead
is coming I
um yeah I just kind of accepted the fact
that I have to play passively and I'm
pretty sure after I play Bishop C2 I
offer to draw I have a score sheet
somewhere uh Square sheet
that's not the score sheets for last few
games I've been playing on the non-dgt
boards just so normal boards with
plastic pieces so my games have not been
broadcast live and I've had to take
notation and manually enter the moves
afterwards
um of course every game I have to take
notation but uh somewhere on my
scoresheet I did Mark that I offered to
draw and my opponent thought for a
little bit and declined and he played on
like even though he's much low rated
um maybe me offering a draw uh was
communicating to him that I think I'm in
trouble which I did think I was in a
little bit of trouble and he correctly
played Rook B8 and now things became
very unpleasant I play Rook B1 he plays
Rook to B2 and it looks like I'm about
to get smushed on the queen side with
black controlling so much space and now
if I take the Rook he would take back
the bishop and if I move the bishop
there's Rook C1 and this is pretty much
game over I guess I have Rook F1 but
then Bishop B5 and oh no my position
so thankfully that didn't happen I found
a better defensive move here played Rook
C1
and after Bishop B5 I realized that the
position is like barely held together my
Rook on v1's defended my Bishops
defended the pawn is blockaded and I'm
not immediately losing this or this
which are both potentially weak pawns so
I figured that there's still some
fighting chances here I played the move
Pawn H4 uh he plays Bishop C4 which is a
great way to improve the bishop I play
Pawn A4 and I was just trying to hold my
own and not uh not lose a pawn now I was
reluctant to play Pawn to A4 because it
fixes a Pawn on the light square but I
figured that it's a bit safer there
because it's always defended by the
bishop and um what was the other reason
oh yeah so I also play A4 because I was
scared of Rook B5 I thought this was one
of the ways for black to make progress
and pawn A4 takes away the B5 Square
so he continues plays Bishop A2 I can't
take his Rook I have to move to A1 and
now it looks like all the pieces are
just stuck uh my my Rook on A1 has no
squares my Rook on C1 is tied down to
the bishop and my Bishop has barely any
moves and then he plays King f8 and at
this point I thought I'm just going down
because I'm almost in zooswang and I
just have to kind of wait on the king
side I start with King F1 he brings his
King in he attacks my Pawn in E5 the
only way to defend it is to play Pawn F4
then he plays Bishop C4 check I play
King F3 he plays Bishop to B3 and it's
actually an interesting position here
because even though I'm a little bit
stuck it's not so clear how black makes
meaningful progress just because the
Rooks can't really improve further and
there's many cases where uh what am I
trying to say yeah there's cases where
like if Bach tries to do anything with
this Rook then I might have Bishop D1
hitting the pawn and
um yeah it's just hard to make progress
for black so the reason why he played
Bishop B3 is to try and transform the
position in some way where he can keep
making progress and uh I guess another
idea of this move is once my Bishop's
removed his King can come in even
further and their dreams for black of
eventually putting me in zug's vine
where I have to retreat my king and then
this King comes very deep into the
position and
um yeah when he played Bishop B3 I I
still was not happy I had to take he
took back and I play Rook to A2 now I
was happy to find this move because if I
don't have Rook a 2
I didn't really see another great
alternative for me initially I wanted to
play Rook C2 but this runs into Rook B2
and in cases where takes takes Rook B1
Rook C2 this is just easily winning for
black because my Rook is completely
passive if I ever move it there's Rook
C1 and this is actually a great example
of White's being in zugzvang let's say
Pawn G3 King F5 every single legal move
for white would be self-destructive like
you can try and find a move but yeah
White's going down one way or another
here
so I was happy with Rook A2 because if
he tries the same idea Rook B2 there's
actually a really funny tactic for light
here which keeps me alive and this is
actually a great puzzle for viewers if
you want to try and find the move feel
free to pause the video uh but the move
is to create a situation where both of
my Rooks are hanging move as Rook takes
C3 and even though both of my Rooks are
hanging both the black Strokes are
hanging so Rooks are very confusing
creatures sometimes they enjoy partaking
and staring contests and in this case I
would just win a pawn because black can
only take one hanging Rook at a time and
then I would take the other Rook so
yeah I was happy uh to at least be
surviving here because Rook B2 seemed
like the only way for black to keep
advancing on the queen side but he plays
King F5 and I'm still like almost in
zogwang I play Pawn G3 and he plays Rook
C4
and I still have to kind of hold my
ground and it seems like my Rook has to
stay defending the pawn but instead of
keeping my Pawn defended I play Rook C2
creating pressure against the C pawn and
I'm offering the pawn trade which of
course he doesn't take but if he does
take on A4 I would be happy to simplify
and I was dreaming of maybe playing for
a win in this position with eventual
Checkmate on F6 but none of that
happened uh he
did not take on A4 he instead played
Rook C6 and moved back to A2 and then he
did something very tricky he played Rook
to C5
and it's a really tricky move because
he's essentially triangulating like he's
trying to lose a Tempo and if I play
Rook C2 here he would play Rook C4 and
this is exact same position we just had
but it's white to move
and I'm pretty sure this is lost for
whites because I'm in zuswang again if I
move either Rook
um Rook B2 is coming they either Rook
Move Along either the first or second
rank for example Rook A2 he would then
have Rook B2 and my same tricky Rook
tactic doesn't work because this Rook is
defended by the pawn from D5 so uh yeah
I think this this would be losing for
white if uh if I return to C2 here
so once you play Rook C5 I saw his evil
intentions and instead of walking into
zugswang I didn't have to commit to C2
because he he's not attacking A4 so I
don't have to counter pressure the C3
Pawn instead of I basically play a
waiting move Rook E2 and then what ends
up happening is he plays Rook C4
I play Rook C2 and we've repeated the
position twice now we've had this
position for a second time he went back
to C6 I go back to A2 he goes to C5 I
play Rook E2
and
um I should note that uh you can see
here his time was getting very low at
this point he had four minutes and 20
seconds left and he was basically taking
the rest of his time trying to find some
way to push forward it was very clear
from his body language he he wanted to
beat me but he got to at some point
below three minutes and then he okay he
did not play C2 there was a mistake on
the broadcast
wait did I say that this game wasn't
live broadcast I lied this game was was
live broadcast it was my next game that
wasn't my broadcast sorry about that
because we do have time stamps here and
there was a mistake at the end he did
not play C2 I'm pretty sure he played
Rook C6 and offered a draw which I was
very happy to accept
um so the game did end in a draw and the
crazy thing is if we turn on the engine
towards the end the stockfish says that
black is like nearly winning here
um like minus two at some point earlier
is close to minus four
but the winning plan is not so simple
and I'm actually really curious if
stockfish misevaluates like it'll say
minus two but I'm not sure if it will
get better for black and I haven't had a
chance to like fully Analyze This in
depth
um just because it's it's been a very
tough schedule so this will be some
homework for me after the tournament to
study this Rook ending and if you find
the truth if black can actually win this
uh one thing I didn't note that if if
black plays F6 ever I can take taken G4
and this would be some progress for me
on the king side but maybe there's lines
where the king can kind of walk into the
queen side uh maybe even walk to B4 uh
may have involved black taking some risk
to try and win the position but
um I was very fortunate to have drawn
this game and I think my opponent just
played a very nice game like understood
the Early Middle game position better
than me especially with this Pawn C4
move is opening preparation I think was
just better like he he neutralized my
London and then uh very quickly just got
the edge so I think I'm very fortunate
to survive this game given that I was
just nearly lost in endgame nearly
zugswanged almost completely Frozen
um I might title this video Frozen Rosen
I'll try and do some fun photoshop with
a thumbnail but anyway I'm gonna wrap it
up here I'm recording this right before
midnight I still have one more game to
play uh I'm recording this after my
round eight game round nines tomorrow so
I hope you enjoy the video if you have
questions leave them below I really
appreciate the comments and feedback and
especially those who subscribe and like
so anyway uh I'm out time to sleep I'll
see you guys soon